one more point before we we move on for
me personally there's a lot of things
that are happening right now that we
should be talking about specifically
World War III that we are probably in
right now the Epstein Client List
Americans are fatter sicker and more
depressed than ever but we're talking
about calendars and cringy t-shirts the
conversation should really be about the
establishment versus the
anti-establishment this is where the
conversation needs to be there's a lot
at stake here and and to me we're we're
arguing over superficial issues when
there's so much deeper things that could
be exposing right now fighting for and
talking about that that sadly we're not
talking about which is kind of
disappointing for me personally I want
to cover some of these issues um I agree
Luke